this was very sudden and I knew what it
was right away and I was terrified Dr
Jennifer Hume caught covet in April
2022. she's been sick ever since I
wasn't able to parent my child
um I couldn't do very basic things with
him even just sensitivity to sound and
noise you can imagine how that affects
your relationships she's still suffering
from long covet a new paper compiled
research from more than 150 studies and
warns just how bad the condition can be
it really is very complex and very
heterogeneous and very challenging it
finds covid to be a multi-organ
multi-system disease that can cause
organ changes even in the absence of a
symptomatic disease it mentions other
studies that point to infections causing
micro blood clots and the virus
remaining in the body one of the authors
says around 10 percent of everyone who
caught the illness gets long coveted
there may be be 400 million people in
the world suffering from it the paper
warns the oncoming burden faced by
Patients health care providers
governments and economies is so large
it's unfathomable and it comes with many
of this country's healthcare workers
already burned out one epidemiologist is
calling for a patient registry to track
symptoms and treatment to learn what
best helps patients there are a lot of
people who are not going to Physicians
even because they have given up hope
Humes says she's almost back to where
she was before she got sick based on her
own search for treatment she says
governments need to create more capacity
and accessibility so patients can get
help we really have to focus on what
people Empower people on what to do when
they do get sick with so many people
affected it's a massive challenge one
that could last as people suffer from
long covet but right now no one knows
how long that will be Nathaniel of
global news